hello we are on FTTH conference and I'm
searching for random person and I will
make some extra interview have you ever
wanted to throw up your pc out of the
window no why should I throw up my pc
window how important is internet in your
life we're very of course yeah count
can't live without it really what kind
of internet connection do you have 30
megabits per second 200 megabits per
second depending on its a cable or they
definitely survivor in the home so yeah
we are interested more because 4k is
coming right so we want to stream in
turn and all the sports as well as
gimmick right what do you think would
change in your life if your internet
connection was always super fast oh I
would always watch movies play video
games I would download a lot of things
and will it will be super awesome if
it's a lot faster okay last question
have you ever wanted to throw your pc
out of the window yes why it's it's
lagging if it's lagging if it's
buffering if I want to watch something
and it's not loading if it's just too
slow Oh all waiting wasting your thing I
feel like it's yeah it's frustrating the
internet is 20 years old it should not
be slow yeah and the last question what
do you think will change in your life if
your internet connection was always
super fast well I would want to throw my
pc out of the window a lot less so yeah
it would be better cheaper also because
no no need to buy a new pc each time so
yeah it will be a would be a lot better
yeah thank you very much it's no problem
thank you yeah and last question what do
you think would change in your life if
your internet connection was always
super fast is it like coming water and
electricity in your own if you don't
have those too what do you think thank
you very much